[Music]
thinking about Gary today one of the
things was so important to me is I
started and some of you know this I
started as a writer I was a writer for a
long time trying to figure out could I
be a performer I'm still trying to
figure that out is that something I
could do
is that something I could maybe one day
achieve and Garry Shandling
started he told me this once that he
started as a writer he was a writer for
years he was inspired by George Carlin
and he went backstage showed George
Carlin some jokes and George Carlin said
you're funny and he started as a writer
and I think he wrote stuff for George
Carlin I think he worked for Sanford &
Son he worked in television for quite a
while as a writer before he got in front
of the camera I remembered hearing about
this guy and seeing him and knowing that
that had been his past and thinking hey
there's a way to do this ya know which
was really cool really fascinate was an
amazing joke right he was an amazing
joke writer all there were all the
comedy writers backstage today have been
trading since they heard the news have
been trading like their favorite Garry
Shandling jokes and they're so smart
they're so good everyone was in awe of
his ability to write such a smart joke
and you also I never knew when he would
be on the show and I'd interview him
what he was gonna do he had such a
different rhythm than everybody else I
think we we today we just thought we'd
take a second and show I believe this is
from 2007 this is what during a period
the show when I had the idea to grow
crazy-long riverboat gambler sideburns
I'm not kidding I did I and I wore them
on the show for like six months until
America said stop it you look like an
ass I don't want you to be thrown by
those sideburns I just wanted to show
this because this shows Gary at work
sitting next to me and just you get to
see his mind working which was so much
fun let's take a look you know I'm not
in New York that much and I had never
seen the linen the linen Memorial and I
couldn't find the captain and Tennille
memorial
here's the here's the part that's not
the part so I turned to my friend and I
said where's the captain and Tennille
memorial my buddy yeah and he laughed
and I said you think I should tell that
on Conan is that funny enough to tell on
Conan and this is the great thing about
New York a guy I didn't know who was
standing there looking at the Lenin
Memorial turned to me and said I think
it's funny enough to do on Conan you
know usually like in LA you got to go
into a nightclub to try jokes you're
gonna walk into Central Park you just
say something out loud and somebody goes
mmm Charlie Rose do that right action
that's good have you gone have you ever
gone to therapy ever look into your eyes
don't take a good look yes I've gone to
therapy of you yeah yeah would you be
interested in going to couples therapy
yes I'm good yeah I know you don't look
right at me you look at my little bit
and then I look right at you you dart
away your eyes dirt away and you're very
is very unsettling for you isn't it well
it's extraordinarily uncomfortable I
don't think the people at home know what
this feels like it's this idea of
building the fences what I can't believe
because is that the best we can do is
build a fence first long I don't I don't
I think all people are the same I'm not
sure how this immigration thing should
work out but they're people but they
tried didn't didn't they try the fence
thing at the Alamo didn't we try it
didn't they build the wall and the
Mexicans had what they call a ladder
they got right oh yeah yeah and what's
the gift shop they're originally at the
Alamo because if I wasn't had a gift
shop uh-huh and I don't know if then the
Mexicans bought the t-shirt that said
I'm in right and and I'm not against a
Mexican person taking my job I wish
George Lopez was here doubt it take over
fold a special fellow indeed